today's video is brought to you by
athletic greens more on them in just a
bit the first century 80 was not a good
time for the Roman Empire the eagle
standard had lost a lot of its luster in
Rome was no longer this nigh invisible
Juggernaut that could make the rest of
Europe tremble into the might of its
Legions the death of Emperor Severus
Alexander in 235 A.D marked the end of
the Severin Dynasty and plunged the
empire into complete Anarchy the
so-called crisis of the 3rd Century with
no air numerous different generals and
politicians tried to claim the throne
for themselves but none of them had the
strength to stand Undisputed Head and
Shoulders Above the Rest the political
instability was accompanied by constant
incursions from Barbarian tribes Civil
Wars peasant rebellions the debasement
of the currency a collapsing economy and
even a plague tacked on for good measure
the Roman Empire saw over 20 Emperors in
a 50-year period and that doesn't take
into account the dozens of Pretenders to
the throne who never got to enjoy their
time in the spotlight most of them only
stuck around for a cup of coffee and
accomplished very little it wasn't until
an emperor named aurelian came along in
270 A.D that he managed to restore some
stemblance of stability but he was
killed after only a few years leaving
his work unfinished in Rome on the brink
of falling back into chaos the very
existence of the empire was under threat
if another capable Emperor didn't finish
what aurelian had started then Along
Came Diocletian he had some far-out
ideas about how to rule the Roman Empire
and they were just crazy enough to work
so did they well let's find out as we
examine the life and career of
Diocletian
foreign
was born on December 22nd Circa 245 A.D
in the Roman province of Dalmatia most
likely in the ancient city of Solona
located in modern-day Croatia he came
from Humble Origins and was known as
darkly's birth although he later adopted
the more grandiose appellation of garas
Aurelius Valeria's dark lucianus because
he was of low status nobody really
bothered keeping records about him so
the first half of diocletian's life has
been lost in the midst of History his
father was either a scribe or a former
slave who once belonged to a senator
named annelinas neither the fathers nor
the mother's names have been recorded
all we really know is that at some point
darkisha married a woman named prisca
and together they had a daughter called
Valeria as we've probably mentioned in
several other biographics videos your
average Roman had two basic ways to
climb up the social ladder either into
politics or the military politics had a
pretty rigid career path called the
curses in aurum which included a series
of public officers necessary in order to
become a senator this route Was Out Of
Reach for most Romans since it required
a lot of money or connections or ideally
both the military approach always more
straightforward enlist stab a lot of
people and get promoted Diocletian chose
the latter we don't know where he went
or what he did but we presume that he
performed well as a soldier around 282
A.D he was promoted to domesticus regans
aka the leader of the Imperial Cavalry
that protected the emperor so obviously
he must have been a pretty skilled
Warrior and military commander are you
looking to upgrade your daily nutrition
routine and supercharger well look no
further than ag-1 by athletic greens
ag-1 is a part of my Wellness routine
and I never skip it partly by something
you can get for free mentioned later in
today's ad read well basically it's very
simple ag-1 is packed with 75 vitamins
minerals and Whole Food Source
ingredients that are essential for your
body's well-being plus it tastes great
it's vanillary it's pineappley they told
me this recently before I was just like
I don't know it just tastes good I just
drink it it's kind of sweet and tasty
and now I'm like you can really smell
the pineapple which is kind of nice it
doesn't look like pineapple but it
tastes like it
it tastes great I haven't started my day
with coffee I feel like it extends that
energy that the coffee gives you and
it's just it's just a part of my well
industry team now age one is everything
my body needs in just a single scoop you
take it from here you pop it in here you
shake it up easy for vitamins and
minerals to pre and probiotics immunity
support and more so if you want to get
started with our leader greens go to
athleticreens.com forward slash
biographics or just click the link in
the description below and you'll also
get a one year supply of vitamin D3 and
also five of these travel packs that's
what I was talking about I uh when you
know if you go on a trip just use some
of these travel packs I've actually got
loads of them I've been using them on
the weekends just at home it's just
easier like I say there's a link below
and now back to today's video the
emperor at that time by the way was a
guy named carus he wasn't incredibly
important he reigned for less than a
year what you need to know is that when
car has adopted the Imperial title of
Augustus he bestowed the title of Caesar
to his two sons numerian and karenus
making them Junior Emperors and heirs to
the throne in early 283 A.D car has
decided to renew the Rivalry with one of
Rome's classic foes Persia now in the
form of the sasanian Empire he made his
way into East Mesopotamia and Ford King
Barham II and was Victorious car has
even captured the sasanian capital of
Stefan but he just didn't know when to
walk away from the table he could have
returned to Rome a triumphant hero but
he decided to press on since it was a
long-standing ambition of many Roman
emperors to conquer all of Persia carus
didn't achieve his goal you'll be
shocked to find out instead he died
sometime during the summer of 283. we
don't know where we don't some ancient
sources claim he was struck by lightning
but a sudden illness seems more
plausible if you are a fan of political
Intrigue though we could suggest a more
Sinister demise for car as perhaps
planned by his perfidious praetorian
prefect APA who was the kind of typical
power-hungry advisor who wouldn't shy
away from an assassination or two with
dear old dad dead as a Dodo the mantle
of Augustus was passed on to his sons
Carlisle was in Gaul at the time trying
to suppress him revolts but numerian had
been alongside his father fighting the
sasanians he assumed control of the army
and tried to settle things in the area
before marching back to Rome the going
was slow however and around Amisa and
Syria numerian also fell ill they be
told the soldiers that the new emperor
suffered from some sort of inflammation
of the eyes sunlight caused him harm
which was why he rode around in an
enclosed litter carried by troops by the
time they reached nicomedia though in
November 284 A.D there was a powerful
stench coming from inside the litter the
soldiers finally dared to open it and
they discovered that they had been
lugging around a corpse numerian had
been dead for a while and it's unlikely
that he died from eye inflammation
an emergency Council was held after
numerian's death with all of his top
General's tribunes and advisors in
attendance the question are was who they
would put up for succession the choice
was mainly between two guys a pub
surprise surprise and the commander of
the Imperial Guard Diocletian as a
lifelong military man the latter had the
support of the army but he made
everyone's Choice even easier when he
accused Aber of assassinating Mariam and
then ran him through with his sword in
front of the entire Army after a
Diocletian himself had to swear an oath
that he had nothing to do with
numerian's death and then he was
proclaimed the new Roman Emperor but who
knows maybe APA wasn't the one who was
guilty after all maybe both Father and
Son really died from different illnesses
or maybe it was all a cunning plot
masterminded by Diocletian himself to
seize the throne but guilty or innocent
if he wanted to assume total power
Diocletian still had the other Caesar
karenus to deal with if Diocletian had
one trait that helped him succeed where
dozens of previous Emperors failed it
was his awareness us and acceptance of
his limitations unlike the stereotypical
Roman Emperor who went mad with power
Diocletian knew that he couldn't do
everything himself and he never even
tried his entire Reign was based on
disseminating power to other people so
that they could carry their share of the
load karenus however was not one of
those people instead Diocletian selected
a man called Lucius saisonius bassas and
officer and Senate who had accompanied
Charis and numerian on their military
expedition to Persia the Two Men were
made consoles and this had a double
effect first and foremost by selecting
his own sidekick Diocletian firmly
rejected karanis's Authority and any
idea that they would rule together
especially with himself as the junior
colleague furthermore Diocletian knew
the golden rule of long and stable Reign
out of Rome's three major groups that's
the Senate the Army and the people you
needed the support of at least two of
them if you didn't want to get poisoned
during dinner or mold in the streets
Diocletian already had the Army on his
side which was why he didn't appoint a
general as his co-consul and instead
opted for a lifelong politician by
allying himself with basses he was
showing everyone that he was looking for
a cordial relationship between the
military and the Senate with battle
lines drawn the two would-be Emperors
gathered their men and met at the Battle
of margas river in July 285 A.D karanus
always the odds on favorite thanks to a
bigger Army but the referee awarded the
victory to Diocletian via assassination
with murky on the details but carolus
was killed by one of his own men at the
outset of the battle so the fight was
cooled off subsequently karenus was
painted with a very unfavorable brush it
was said that he slept with his
officer's wives and that he had anyone
who complained executed how much of that
was true and how much was propaganda
done to please Diocletian we cannot say
but it could explain why his own men
hated the guy anyway with Karen as dead
the path was now clear for Diocletian to
become the sole ruler of the Roman
Empire
or was it
foreign
was someone who understood that no man
is an island at that point in time with
Rome and the weakened and unstable state
that it was it was simply too big for
one guy to rule on his own the emperor
had lots of fires to put out all over
the Empire and no matter how capable he
was he still couldn't be in multiple
places at the same time so Diocletian
did something that most other Emperors
Kings pharaohs and other monarchs would
rather die than do he willingly
relinquished some of his power for the
first time in history he divided the
Roman empire into two halves with one
Emperor ruling the west and another
ruling the East but who to select as his
co-emperer his fellow console bassers
would have seemed like an obvious choice
but he was snubbed for the position
probably due to his Advanced age
Diocletian opted to make him prefect of
Rome which was still a nice gig but it
was a few steps below Emperor instead
Diocletian selected one of his most
trusted generals maximian he too came
from Humble origin so maybe that
endeared him to the emperor but it's far
more likely that maximian supported
Diocletian during his conflicts with
aper and karanus and had proved his
loyalty to him even so better safe than
sorry thought Diocletian so he put
maximian on a trial run first he gave
him the title of Caesar which was like a
junior Emperor and only a year later in
286 A.D did maximian become Augustus he
was equal to Diocletian well almost as
the batter still retained the authority
to veto any decisions made by the former
as far as Their Kingdoms were concerned
Diocletian had never been a fan of Rome
considering it her City full of spoiled
brats drunks and layabouts who are used
to enjoying the fruits of the Empire
simply because they lived in Rome
therefore he elected to Reign Over the
eastern half of the Empire and selected
nicomedia as its new capital in itself
this was a momentous event in the
history of the Roman Empire up till that
point the city of Rome had always been
the Empire's Center of power for the
first century and a half of the Empire's
existence and certainly during the
Republic yet every important political
and administrative decision was made in
Rome then during the 2nd Century A.D
Hadrian had been the first emperor to
spend the majority of his Reign outside
the city but he still visited it from
time to time and was regularly kept
apprised of the goings-on inside the
city but Diocletian had forsaken it
completely turning nikomedia into the
Empire's new center of power and his
trusty sidekick maximian followed suit
even though his side of the Empire
actually included Rome he decided that
he didn't like the city either and moved
his Capital to medialarnum better known
today as Milan now that the
administrative issues all were dealt
with the two Emperors moved to resolve
the various armed conflicts that plagued
their Empires truth be told maximian had
his work cut out for him since his side
of the empire was far more susceptible
to Germanic incursions probably another
reason why diet Alicia wanted a skill
generally not a politician as his
co-auugustus maximian was successful at
putting down revolts and incursions from
Frank's Saxons and Gauls but was bested
by one of his own officers a guy named
caracious who became powerful enough to
revolt against the Roman Empire and
claim Britain a northern Gaul for
himself proclaiming to be the Augustus
of that newly formed Kingdom meanwhile
Diocletian was busy in the East with the
psalmatians and the Persians but neither
proved to be too difficult to deal with
ultimately Darkly shouldn't realize that
maximian could use his help so in 288
A.D he packed up his army and traveled
to the West Side to lend a hand
caracious had a strong foothold on his
territory by this point as well as the
North Sea so reluctantly the Emperors
had to accept a humiliating peace
between the two sides instead they
decided to focus their wrath on the
Germanic tribes that kept invading from
the north particularly the Alemany the
two armies attacked the German
Confederation from different sides
enacting scorched Earth policies along
the way to deter them from returning
with one major threat sorted Diocletian
returned to the East and maximian was
free to concentrate on carousius once
again but Diocletian wasn't exactly a
spring chicken anymore and Leading
Armies was a young man's game the issue
of succession came up and that's when he
had a brain wave this whole two
Emperor's idea seemed to be working so
if two was good then four it would
surely be better right
in 293 A.D Diocletian instituted the
tetricky or the rule of four each
Augustus would select a junior Emperor
or Caesar who would eventually become
August I themselves when the originals
retired and then appoint their own
Caesars basically the concept followed
the Sith guidelines for each half of the
Empire always two there are a master and
an apprentice and when we say that each
Augustus chose their Caesar we actually
mean that Diocletian chose them both
unsurprisingly maximian all wanted his
son maxentius to inherit his kingdom but
Diocletian mixed the idea possibly
feeling that maxentius or wasn't up to
Snuff he had read a history book or two
and knew what happened when nepo babies
became Emperors Marcus Aurelius
basically did the same thing as him much
earlier but his plan backfired by
electing his own son Commodus as his
co-empora and he was a pants on head
lunatic you don't believe us just check
out our video on Commodus anyway
Diocletian selected constantius clorus
has maximum Caesar the father of
Constantine the Great over on the east
side he named galerius as his own Caesar
and also gave him his daughter's hand in
marriage the Caesars were both
experienced military commanders they
were expected to handle the bulk of the
fighting from then on constantius
probably had it the hardest since he now
had the task of dealing with karasias
fortunately for him crouses was betrayed
and assassinated by his Treasurer
electus and about 296 A.D constantius
had managed to regain all of the
territories once lost to the usurper
Diocletian was probably hoping that this
tetricky Malarkey would let him King up
his feet a little bit and take it easy
but that was not to be in 297 A.D he had
his own usurper to deal with in Egypt a
guy named achillius that was a pretty
straightforward Affair though Diocletian
laid Siege to Alexandria and eventually
captured and executed the man but it
took him eight months to do it more
problematic for him was the sasanian
Empire which was battered again they had
a new king named narcis and unlike his
predecessors he had no desire to stay
subservient into Rome he declared war on
the Roman Empire in 296 A.D and as was
the tradition with the conflicts between
the Romans and the Persians he invaded
Armenia the kingdom that had the
misfortune of constantly acting as a
buffer between the two larger more
powerful Empires afterward he pressed on
to Syria which was a Roman province so a
pitched battle between the two sides
became inevitable first up was hilarious
he was the young Caesar after all it was
his job to deal with Invaders In The
East the two armies fought somewhere
near kahei but narciss delivered a
stunning and decisive defeat to the
Romans prompting galarius to fall back
and regroup with Diocletian who was
returning from Egypt According to some
sources Diocletian wasn't thrilled with
his Junior Emperor's performance and
upon meeting Galleria he humiliated him
in public by refusing to a lamb inside
his Carriage instead making him walk in
front of it who knows maybe the
humiliation little far under hilarious
or maybe it was all the extra soldiers
but he now launched a successful
counter-attack on narcissus pushing the
sasanians out of the Roman Empire and
delivering them a crushing defeat at
satala into 198 A.D before advancing
into Persian territory and capturing the
sasanian capital of stessifon we don't
know if Diocletian also tagged along or
not but ultimately a humbled narcissus
was forced to admit defeat and ended the
war with the Peace of nisibis in 299 a
treaty that unsurprisingly favored the
Romans
with the new century Dawning on the
Roman Empire Diocletian had been
successful in ridding his kingdom of
external threats so he turned his gaze
inwards to see who threatened the Empire
from within the answer was those pesky
Christians by that point Christianity
had been around in the Roman Empire for
centuries some Emperors were more
tolerant than others but none of them
fully embraced this new religion yet
Diocletian had ever been a fan of
Christianity he thought that any
deviation from the traditional Roman
gods caused instability and he was all
about restoring stability to the shaken
Empire so maybe it was time for some
good old-fashioned persecutions we can't
really say for sure what prompted him
maybe he always wanted to do it but he
was too busy with other stuff in the
first two decades of his Reign or maybe
his ego got too big and he was angry at
the Christians because they refused to
acknowledge him as a living God maybe it
was glarius who actually had it in for
the Christians since he not only
encouraged their oppression but
continued it well after Diocletian was
out of the picture whatever the reason
at the outset of the 4th century be
directly and enacted some of the
harshest persecutions that Roman
Christians ever had to endure churches
were raised to the ground holy
scriptures were burned Christians were
arrested had their property confiscated
and were tortured and even executed this
became known as the great persecution it
lasted from 303 to 311 A.D and I think
we all know how effective it was at
eradicating Christianity from the Empire
just a few years later Constantine the
Great became the first Christian Roman
Emperor maybe it was Karma but in 304
A.D Diocletian suffered a big Health
scare we're not sure what it was but it
incapacitated him for a while as fears
grew that he might even die he survived
but the close school made Diocletian
realize that just like Danny Glover he
was getting too old for this bit just
the previous year it celebrated 20 years
on the throne so maybe it was time for
him to hang up his sandals as we've
already seen Diocletian wasn't a guy who
had problems letting go of power so he
decided to do something that no other
Roman Emperor had done before him
essentially said screw you guys I'm
retiring although it probably sounded
more magisterial in Latin and so it was
on May the first 305 A.D Diocletian
abdicated allowing hilarious to become
the new Augustus he persuaded maximian
to do the same thing for constantius so
technically both of them became the
first Roman Emperor to retire since they
did it on the same day however it became
pretty clear that this hadn't been
entirely voluntary on maximian's part
since he tried to regain power a few
years later lost and then was forced to
commit suicide Fierce bar Diocletian was
happy with his retired life he retreated
to his Palace and his homeland of
Dalmatia where he spent most of his time
in his Gardens tending to vegetables he
was even asked to come back in 308 but
he turned down the opportunity saying
that anyone who could see how big and
lovely his cabbages were would
understand Diocletian died peacefully of
old age Circa 311 A.D he lived long
enough to see his tetricky fail and
collapse into chaos plunging Rome into
Total War once more although the idea
might have been good on paper it
constantly relied on four men all being
satisfied with only a fraction of the
power
Diocletian had selected his Confederates
carefully and all of them were happy
with the system but as soon as the
original four were out of the picture it
was back to betrayals rebellions murder
plots and conspiracies just like the
good old Rome that we know and love